hello and welcome everyone to this
meeting of the council my first remind
you of some domestic arrangements the
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until your self
told it was safe to do so and please
would you switch off all mobile phones
or turn them to silent I would like to
remind everyone present this meeting
will be broadcast live to the to the
Internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except where there are
confidential or exempt items if you make
a representation to the meeting you'll
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you're also consented to be
filmed by the council and the possible
use of those images and sound recordings
to webcasting and/or for training
purposes the council members of the
public and the press may record film or
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press not
lawfully excluded finally can members
and officers please ensure that you
press the microphone for speaking and
turn it off when you are finished and
then can I move the agenda please
members are moving item 12 the capital
investment fund company Cisco the
business trading and performance report
2018 to 19 to further on in the agenda
which should be taken before item 15 all
other items will remain the same in the
same order so agenda item number 1
apologies for absence Thank You chair
I've received apologies so far from
councillor Passmore
yes counselor Madison yes I'm afraid um
counselor Amoroso
is some unable to get here at the moment
because the lack of trains running Thank
You counselor field counselor Phillips
and Norris I think I've also presented
their apologies um Thank You chair you
should have counsel eternal already
listed because she's on holiday item
number two declarations of interest by
counselors are there any declarations
yes counselor brewster thank you madam
chairman
yes on MC 1916 the city code capital
limited Thank You counselor madam
chairman as a pizza the same exactly
same thank you
agenda item three MC / 19 stash 11 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 27th of June 2019 for accuracy
only are there any issues with accuracy
yes can slaughter yes could I ask why it
was not Minnie cage that I asked the
leader presentation who was leaving
after 20 odd years
and in fact counsel Amal he did in fact
reply and Thank You chair councillor
Oliver and Watson was at the meeting and
he's not listed as an it indeed thank
you thank you that can be added
counselor thank you I just like to
correct paragraph eleven point five on
page fourteen I did not ask about
figures for school sites but stalled
start sites that's sta double led which
is what the report was about thank you
how could I have a seconder yes madam
chairman I'm happy to second thank you
right I'll take a boat then those in
favor let amended thank you that's
carried I'm signed this later thank you
so that's agenda item number four the
Chairman's announcements I refer you to
paper MC / 19 / 12 to be noted and I'm
moving on search and a title number five
the leaders announcements I'd like to
invite counselor Morley to present her
table to update Thank You chair and I've
submitted my report to you and I'm happy
to take any questions
councillor ebin no sorry
thank you I just like to comment on your
item number six of your report about the
portfolio reports and I just wondered
whether it would be easier for us and
possibly other people if they were not
all the portfolio reports were not
brought to the same meeting it would be
much better if we could have one or two
each meeting at quarterly intervals each
one because otherwise we end up having
an awful lot of things to question the
portfolio holds on in one particular
meeting and I thought that's what we had
discussed some time ago but it hasn't
happened yet so I wondered if that could
be put into your program of when they're
going to be brought forward we've been
looking at aligning the timing of our
performance reports with the portfolio
holder reports because very often a lot
of the questions are asked on the
portfolio and reports are actually
answered by the performance reports and
at the moment they come to two different
meetings one goes to cabinet and one
goes to Council
in different months so we're looking at
aligning those and the first one's going
to be coming in September we have not
discussed separating them out so that we
have two two reports each council but I
think that would give us a problem with
our performance report we were to do
that Chancellor Ebert Thank You chair
and firstly I could ask the same
question that I asked that last council
meeting that whether we could have this
please in advance and not just done five
minutes in advance because it's
obviously difficult for us then to
formulate questions that might arise
from what we've read on this report so
I'd appreciate it if we could have it
have it further in advance rather than
just a few minutes with regards to our
item to the five-year housing land
supply please could I ask if we as
members could get some advice on how we
are dealing with that five point six one
figure because it's currently being
mentioned at in planning committees and
their parish councils and so on and so
could we be given some advice as to how
we are going to be using that and the
certainty of that figure thank you very
much
Hansen Wally would you like to answer
that
like the answer the question is that we
will be using that figure until the
consultation is complete and of course
it will depend on on the responses as to
whether we have to deal with any
challenges to that figure one way or the
other so as soon as that happens we will
start to be applying that 5.6 bone if it
stays that their figure which I have no
reason to think is that a satisfactory
answer to your question I can't give you
a date unfortunately I can't I mean it's
a four-week consultation consultation
started it's the 15th of August in
something like that and then I should
imagine that it won't be too long after
that we will be able to announce that
it's a it's a firm figure okay yes on
the thin rounds and the changes ident
about others but I have had numerous and
emails and complaints on that and
certainly not everyone received a
notification letter so I can't
altogether agree with you saying it's
very successful but I would really urge
the cabinet member to look at that
almost on a day to day basis because it
is still causing massive confusion it is
being looked at on a day to day basis
there have been a few issues where the
bin red the bin men or women are new to
the rounds they don't necessarily know
all the roads and some of the little
roads are have been missed
but we've got extra crews under stand by
and as soon as anybody contacts Aspire
the
the website or the customer care line
then bid men are out within a couple of
days to resolve the issue on a normal
week our miss rate is about 50 billions
of the week considering the amount of
changes that we've made which is
affected over 70% of our 40,000 domestic
bins then I still believe that missing
only 200 is successful councillor
stringer thank you very much I was
expecting there to be a mention of myths
of its involvement in the Ipswich
northern route consultation because
we're helping to fund it I was going to
ask how much is missing educational
spending on that consultation
it's actually funding through suffer
public sector leaders from our joint
quads rather than individual councils is
there any other questions okay moving on
to agenda item six to receive
notifications or petitions in accordance
with council procedure rules Thank You
chair none received item number seven
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules again not
received thank you
gender item eight questions by
councillors in accordance with council
procedure rules question number one
councillor Madison - councillor Fleming
yes I can I just thank accounts the
claiming for the answer would you like
to read out your question I asked as
indeed I did a few months ago how many
public electric vehicle charging points
have actually been installed in mid
Suffolk Council Fleming would you like
to read out your answer yes the answer
is one but it's a large one it's one of
the faster
it's a fast charger 50 kilowatt and
that's in medium legs and need a market
now we do have plans for more using the
plug-in suffered program and even we
hope to increase coverage that's part of
the agenda that I hope we will be
pursuing but at the moment in terms of
public points where you can just roll up
I'm afraid it's one do you have a
supplemental I don't suppose we know
where these other two are that you the
audition of sorry additional three up
would be found out where they are yet I
don't know that but I can get back to
you and I also do refer anyone with
queries to the Zachman which provides a
very accurate and up-to-date indication
of where any type of charge point public
or not is located I'm moving on to item
number nine the overview and scrutiny
committee report I would like to invite
counselor Elam to introduce his report
which is for noting
councillor pinyon I don't have a
question madam chairman but I was in
attendance of the meeting and it's not
recorded councillor geek thank you when
the when the housing delivery action
plans being considered committee and as
part of this will overview and scrutiny
consider who's actually doing the work
is there a new and a separate team being
set up or existing staff being seconded
to the task and if the latter is true
then will they be backfilled thank you
for the question yes we will be
scrutinizing the effect of the last of
the first six months I would be looking
at it in January 2020 and I'm sure that
staffing will be one of the aspects that
we will be looking at if there is any
information that we can glean in the
meantime that might be helpful then
obviously we'll we'll pass that on but
the full report to scrutiny is
anticipated in January 2020 Thank You
councillor autumn did you have a
question and I'm not sure if the
question should go to the chair of
scrutiny or to the cabinet member that
is part of the Needham Lake Development
I know obviously at the moment you're
looking at obviously a visitor center
but I'm just wondering whether it's part
of that work would you be can consider
looking at whether there could be a wild
swimming area within the lake complex
something that's extremely popular at
the moment and I think let's face it
it's whether some of us would have been
in there thank you thank you would you
like to respond
yes well I wouldn't recommend swimming
in needham lake at the moment with the
amount of ducks but however I'm as an
avid wild swimmer myself I think that if
there's any possibility of getting an
area that's clean enough and it has
enough fresh water running through it I
would be absolutely all for it I think
you know obviously there are dangers
there health and safety issues with wild
swimming but it's something that let's
take a look at it and see if there's
anywhere that it might be safely done
Thank You councillor Madison thank you
Jeff
yeah can I ask the chair of scrutiny if
the they could consider putting onto
their work plan a look at our IT service
particularly the sort of download speeds
that our staff are experiencing both
here but also at home and in the other
places that they work meet yeah thank
you casual matheson we will be looking
at the work plan for forthcoming months
next week the chairs and vice chairs
will be getting together and if there is
something there which we can usefully
scrutinize then we will be suggesting
that at the next joint scrutiny mating
is a joint it will be a joint screw a
screw to me rather than just mid stuff
I'm looking at it but we will look to
see if there's anything that we can add
value to certainly it seems a good idea
thank you is there any other questions
so moving on to agenda item number 10 to
update
thank you very much Oh with the scrutiny
of the five-year housing land supply and
the housing delivery test would it be
appropriate to look at this provision
for traveller transit sites for
travelers within this thank you thank
you for the question and the the
scrutiny committee meeting join scrutiny
committee considered whether or not this
was something which we could usefully
look at and a couple of the members of
the joint scrutiny committee are looking
to see whether there is something we can
usefully do around this this this whole
aspect and we will expect to have some
some sort of response at the next
meeting as to whether or not it's soon
it's sensible to set up our own task
force to have a look at it or whether we
should work with the the people who have
already been set up as a steering group
thank you
I'm counselor Maury would you like to
add something to that Thank You chair
and I can tell you that as part of the
public sector leaders group there is
they're looking at gypsy and traveler
sites and it may be as well to wait
until they report back to the public
sector leaders agreed before determining
the timing of that
bouncing Thank You counselor Molly is
there any other questions so moving on
to agenda item 10 the update on midst
Africa District Council's police
communities for support officers I would
like to invite inspector Sean wait link
to present his verbal update Thank You
chair and first of all my apologies I
did bring a PowerPoint but unfortunately
I haven't got they in the USB format so
that means that I can't share it with
you I mean what we've agreed is that
should anyone wish to have a look at
that just get in touch with myself all
Melanie Yelland and we'll get it
forwarded over to you so as introduced
I'm sure waiting and on the inspector
over at Stone Market and I cover a great
number of parishes where I am but also
what I should say is that the way that
Suffolk police set up our boundaries is
somewhat different to the way councils
do and therefore there are a couple of
other inspectors that cover cover areas
in mid Suffolk so other inspectors do
have an input on what happens with the
PCSOs and if I may so that I don't have
my back to everyone it's okay if I sit
down but talk me through the process of
what's gone on and so first and foremost
that our two PCSOs bill butcher and
Lizzy Porteous and pcso butcher joined
us in January of 2019 and pcso Porteous
was in March this is a two year fixed
term contract until at the end of
January in 2021 and initially PCSOs are
working jointly because
pcso Porteous was new to that role and
therefore needed an 8-week tutorship and
mentorship with pcso butcher and and
that's now taken place and they now work
opposite shifts so that there's a
greater coverage across the whole of mid
Suffolk with me we've also got the two
poster sorry I just need to
the way that the way that that works is
that their work in five days a week
their core hours and from zero 800 until
1800 but there's two different shifts so
one is zero 800 until 1600 and one is
ten hundred hours until 1800 hours like
I say they try to split their time there
and also they do a week in Rory rural
areas and then they'll do a week in
Stowe market as well hopefully this
maximizes coverage in areas that have
got a greater call for it ie the bigger
towns have a large pool but also it then
does mean that those other outlying
rural areas get service as well they've
got access to vehicles and bicycles but
most patrols are undertaken on in the
cars and then obviously a large amount
on foot as well and their workloads
consist of proactive and reactive
taskings they're dictated by the mid
Suffolk & District Council referrals
which I'll talk through in a second and
they're what I call roll appropriate
cads so obviously if it's a something
that comes in to us and which is more
appropriate for a police officer to do
then obviously we won't be sending them
so the referral process involves
councillors completing a PCSO referral
form providing details and to us that
are of concern and sending it through
and the communities safe offices many
Yolen when Taylor violet via the
referral form and that can be found on
the members area and connect on the
in-house internet referrals are logged
then refer to the name contact in to us
in the police for a review and as long
as it fits the remit that sort been
agreed of the PCs those duties then
they'll be tasked to look into that once
the matter has been investigated PTSO
will complete and
Marie of action taken turn in turn
provide feedback to the councillor Clark
who submitted it and then that can be
reported back to the individual who's
initially raised that concern so that's
the sort of staggered process that we go
through they're also from mid-may it's
worth mentioning that we've allowed that
process or made that process available
to parish clerks as well and so parish
councils can raise concerns and I did
have a slide for you where all of the
referrals have been highlighted and so
I'll talk you through them now Ricky
Hall Elms well ring shil Mendel Shem I
Ollie
Stowe market Stowe upland Stradbroke
Devon and Finn bruh well from the
Willows rattles Dhin and Needham market
now whilst that is a good number of
referrals from different areas there are
still others and that haven't and I
don't know if that's because at this
juncture we haven't had calls to or if
people aren't aware of how they go about
that referral process so that's why
thought is pertinent to remind you all
of how how that process works and should
you need to then you now know how and so
monthly performance reports are
completed by the PCSOs they detail the
numbers of parking tickets advisory
issues and intelligence reports any good
news stories those types of things that
they've been doing and what they've been
involved in and we send them on to our
communities officers as well and that
does help create an audit trail and and
also just keeps us in line with what our
service level agreement was again I've
got got some statistics for you I don't
want to bore anyone but total today in
terms of parking tickets we're at 237
and advisory notice is we're at 25
they've been a large number in church
walk and Ipswich Road were those some
parking restrictions and 65% of psso
referrals received have been for parking
related concerns and parking out school
outside schools continues to be an issue
at various localities and we take those
on board and obviously get in touch with
the schools and and try to do our best
to resolve those issues as well as we
can and speeding is obviously a big
issue as well in terms of concerns for
people and we've sent out in excess of
60 warning letters to people which i
think are quite impactive i've got i've
got a strong belief in that intelligence
reports is one that's really important
to us especially in our bigger bigger
areas like Stowe market because they can
be really instrumental in us having an
impact on county lines and drug dealing
and between two of them they've
submitted over 44 intelligence reports
30 of which do relate to county lines
and drug dealing and high visibility
patrols are always conducted where
possible and they attend regular
community engagements with the elderly
in vulnerable communities these include
and the jam pot and need a market
internet cafe I County Market avenues
east and thorned and coffee morning
welcome The Willows coffee morning the
community hub and Meetup Mondays in
various different locations and they
undertake a number of reassurance input
various events and local concerns things
such as its dough market high school
they've been there for up sector and a
knife crime and that we've been trying
to assist in educating young people
about and they've been to stop at high
school in relation to bullying so Robert
hitch and primary had some issues and
with kids taking sweets and stationery
from one another so it was right for
bill and Lizzy to get involved there and
like I said they go to meet up Mondays
and a few other things as well and there
there are a couple of case studies that
they've provided me with into also good
news stories if you like so I'll just go
over them because they're really keen
for me to tell you all what they've been
up to so and they really do do a great
job so following the referral on the 4th
of June Prentiss Road was visited every
day for the week and the referral with
frequent visits thereafter it meant that
multiple tickets were issued over the
month and this appears to have made a
really noticeable difference as cars are
no longer parking on the double yellow
lines and Prentiss Road is added to the
PCSOs parking patrol routes which
they've created as well so they've got
regular areas where they'll go and
patrol they attended crucial crew and
which I think probably most of you be
aware of but they've assisted in the
delivery of that it's a massive sort of
engagement project where we speak with
young people and basically provide a lot
of safety advice on a range of subjects
from gangs to being befriended online
and I think they stay sand or had
interactions with over a thousand people
so lots and lots of interaction there
that was really really well-received
there was some concerns in Hawley over
some unsafe parking by HGVs and trailers
visit was undertaken and we had some
communications with that with the
company there who quickly got those
issues sorted and rectified they
realized they needed to find
alternatives I think we were the
catalyst to helping them get that done a
little bit sooner rather than later and
so yeah there are there are a number of
different things that bill and Lizzy
have been up to and from my perspective
it's been great to have them working
they Lizzy for example who was new to
this role and has taken to it look at
that
to water and is really thriving
especially now that she's on her own
she's able to generate her own workload
as well as be receiving those referrals
bill is someone that's got a lot of
experience and that experience has
really helped and in the mid Suffolk
area and he certainly knows how to get
out and about and really has worked hard
to know his patch and so I'm very
pleased for both of them they take on a
great deal of work from my perspective
and it will it's great to have them and
along that continue thank you very much
are you happy to answer questions yeah
I'll do my best certainly well thank you
very much
I'm sure thank you it's not really a
question it's a vote of thanks really I
don't think I'm alone within this
chamber to say thank you thank you for
your service and thank you PCSOs
it's a real success story in stone
market they're making a massive
difference they're visible they're
effective and above all they're really
popular so PCs a butcher and porches
they're the face of the police force and
they're doing an incredible job so thank
you service and long meant continue
thank you very much I know that I've
seen both of them tomorrow
and so I told him I'll give him a little
debrief on on how the meeting goes and
to hear things like that will really
boost their confidence and continue to
ensure that it carries on Thank You
councillor Fleming
[Music]
thank you for sending you know PSC pcso
came up to ripping halt when we had some
trouble with anti-social behaviour there
and he's been really helpful and has
actually gone and visited families and
that's exactly what we need and you know
what has been lacking I would like to
say that we did think it would be very
nice if the PCSO daily schedule could be
shifted a little bit so they had for
evening time and came on a bit later and
maybe could leave later in the evening
so I suppose I'm posing more of a long
term query to you is there any
flexibility in particularly summer
months in enabling them to shift their
schedules so that they could work a
little bit later and therefore maybe
cover some of the evening anti-social
behaviour they can go on you understand
that that is something that people would
would like to see unfortunately with the
the contracts as they are and the way
that it's not just about those two
individuals because obviously they're
part of a wider group of PCs so some of
which aren't funded and it becomes a
much bigger question for all in the past
obviously that was the case and then it
and then it was changed and so I won't
say that it will never happen again but
I think it's unlikely in the near future
councillor Flatman mine too is a vote of
thanks strat brick school has been
visited and at the schools other high
schools went to that meeting and I think
heartis may were quite impressed as well
so thank you that was the drug-related
thank you thank you it's really positive
feedback what I will say is that please
don't be afraid to tell me sure you
wouldn't but if there are any areas
where you think we can improve or what
we could do better and I am I am keen to
hear those things as well so and even if
that doesn't come at this point that
there's nothing raised of course in a
future if there are things they can get
through Masseria
and just let it let us know where we can
continue to improve because that would
be what the goal is and just come back
to your point although they are funded
and there are set hours of course have
been the neighborhood inspector myself I
do consider the bigger picture and I do
have resources that are able to work
later so it's not just that these two
pcs those are the only option for us to
deal with those types of issues and if
it is right and again you'd have heard
this time and time again but if the
threat and harm and risk is is enough to
sanction us or warrant us sending
resources at those types of times to
make sure that we can be impacted then
we will be yes I would like to concur
exactly with what everybody else says
but I'm also a local police volunteer so
I do work quite closely with some
members of Shawn's team and in addition
to the two PCSOs I would like to pass on
my sincere thanks to PC Stefan
Hendrickson who I do have quite a lot of
dealings with passing on information
from residents was extremely helpful and
I can assure you Shawn that the
residents really appreciate the help
he's been able to give as well well
thank you very much thank you sorry
could I'll just take a second to respond
to that just just because yet again
that's another thing that is a
relatively new role and Stephanie's our
engagement officer so it's great to hear
that people feel like his role that has
got a good value and I think it
hopefully it makes people feel a bit
like the old days in terms of having
that regular point of contact and
knowing who the person is to go to and
yet at the same time from a policing
perspective we're still able to get on
with what is our more core business if
you like but we have an understanding of
what people's concerns are we're still
at a point where we won't always be able
to take action against those concerns
and with immediacy but the more they
reported and the more we
understand and build our intelligence
picture then we are actually able to
respond and I know that there was
something recently that Steph took hold
of in the Cedars area that we took a
grip of and and it's been very helpful
to have people come forward and help and
give us information in that respect so
thank you Dave and I'll pass on the
congrats to step counselor Wellum Thank
You chair if it's not too boring can I
say thank you as well
thank you for coming along to start with
high school I think both of the PCSOs
came along to start with high school and
I think they need a return visit it's
probably the case with all schools that
a return visit in September will be
necessary just to see whether there's
been any effect or whether everybody's
forgotten everything over there over the
summer holidays I've got one or two
other queries and you said that some
parish clerics can refer I hadn't
realized that until we had a report back
to the old Newton parish Klockner I
don't think I'll dude was only on this
perhaps that's because it was the parish
park who who who were informed you and
will the will the ward member be
informed when the referral is made
because we knew nothing about it until
until the end of the procedure could I
could ask for a breakdown of referrals
between say rural but not this minute
a rural urban and stone market because
it seems a lot of a lot of the time
seems to be taken up in stone market
which is good quite a number 237 parking
tickets possibly possibly most of them
it's in stone market but I think we who
are in the rural areas have got to be a
bit careful because to most residents
out in the sticks they don't they don't
really care if there's parking problems
in stone well because they rarely go
there
so yeah whilst that I guess from your
point of view that's a good thing and
slow market members
I think it's a good thing it does seem a
lot of time is taken up with something
which doesn't put lives at risk s-- at
risk generally sorry I've got two more
questions
one is to do with speeding referrals can
can PCSOs initiate speeding tickets I
understand that all they can do is
initiate warning letters and you spoke
about drug dealing I guess that if we
know about or with we're concerned about
potential drug dealing we still ring the
police we don't put in a PCSO referral
sorry it's a long list of questions no
it's no problem I will try to answer as
many as I can remember but if not then
just job job my memory and so starting
in reverse order I guess and yeah
absolutely
let us know and not by the referral
process and will do will essentially
triage that piece of information and
decide at what level it needs to go in
at and I won't again take up too much of
your time explaining all of that but yes
if if drug dealing activity is seen let
us know I mean it can can just be a
simple email into the SMT box but to the
point where if you think it is so
serious or people are in danger and it
could warrant a 999 call although
unlikely I would say it's more of an
intelligence building thing and if we
have the resources we would deal with it
at that at that juncture as well so yes
please please do let us know no peace
Essos can't issue fixed penalty knows
notices in relation to speeding but as
you say those warning letters are
something that can be can be issued and
can go out and again I do i I know some
some people say oh it's a shame that
they can't you know yeah actually give
them fines that I understand that
perspective personally I think it's
quite a positive thing because you can
alienate members of public when they're
given speeding fines and
and in this way it's kind of like a
reminder and a let off if you like to
the individual but hopefully and they
don't repeat that same mistake again so
I do think it does have a place and I
devalue what what they do there where
were we before that one balance between
two things parking and other things and
rural and urban yes so I think the
answer to that is that and actually and
the two sort of go hand-in-hand to
certain extent so as I said they will do
a week in each and now I appreciate when
you're doing a week in rural that means
half a day in some areas or a day in
areas where a stone market to get that
whole week and there will always be a
difficulty in striking a balance and
sits right with people and and obviously
those in Stowe will say great and those
in rural will say we want you more you
have to try and balance it somehow
whether you do it by and sort of like a
demand process or whether you do it by a
sort of a population process I
personally feel we have got it about
right but it is something that we would
be happy to review and and of course our
aim is to try and keep everyone happy
not just Stowe market or not just those
rural areas so it would be something
that would be prepared to look at but I
personally feel at the moment that it is
it is about where we would want it to be
and Anna Anna and of course has to bring
me on to the sort parking point and well
it's saying relations that would be yes
I know that that doesn't offer a lot of
threat harm and risk but the reality of
these roles is that that's that's kind
of what the money's being spent on
because the rhetoric has been that we
haven't been focusing on those types of
issues our response is that we just
can't do that in this day and age and ah
here's an option that does cover that
for you however it comes where you would
need
contribute in order to achieve it so I
think that if that's a problem in Stowe
market area and that's what they'd like
to be looked at then we're more than
prepared to do that and they'll put some
good work into it if that's not what is
required in other rural areas and Rickon
hoteles that they've got an ASB problem
then we'll come up there and we'll focus
our attentions on the ASB so it's really
just about us looking at the diverse
issues in different areas and trying to
deal with them as they presented you
councillor Richardson I'm sorry they're
possible there was one other um there
was one other question which I think
Melanie probably will deal with and by
way of my wife coming back will the
parking tickets arrangement will that
change with the civil enforcement okay
there's two questions I was going to
answers good answer the one about the
notification of the councillors as well
in relation to the parking my
understanding is something the
enforcement is coming in in October 2009
teen so I think everything will be
looked at after that date wrong and in
relation to a notification of to ward
councillors and district councillors we
opened it up in June this year the cond
Khamsin to paragraph a to advise parish
and Town Council's directly that they
could actually make the ferals into the
PCSOs for us that it's open to not just
the parish clerks it is open to all of
the parish and town councillors as well
and what we've started to do is actually
notify the district councillors that
referrals have been been referred you
know things have come into the PCSOs
just so that you are aware of what's
going on in your in your parishes in
your town so that will continue thank
you
Thank You councillor which is it thank
you very much chair I'm going to jump on
the bandwagon a little bit and say thank
you both for your very interesting
report but also for the hard work that
you and your your colleagues do I mean
my dad was an inspector in south I could
study for many years so I can I know
from personal experience exactly how
hard working and
determined our pcs and our PCSOs are but
I do have a couple of questions first
system with regards just similar
question about whether you've received a
referral from first and parish council
my understanding is this should have
been a referral about antisocial
behavior so she wondered if that was in
your list so I just wanted to clear that
with you and then secondly about the two
pcs in question is will there be an
opportunity for us to meet both bill and
Lizzy Gazoo sir excuse me there's a new
council myself it'd be fantastic to make
them to both thank them for their work
but also to get a better understanding
of the kind of issues that they deal
with in our communities and to kind of
understand exactly where those where
there's issues like um in relation to
the the thirst in question that's
something that we can just double check
for you and obviously is not on my list
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it hasn't come in and so we double check
that and and get back to you in relation
to to meeting their might I can't see
why we wouldn't be able to do that but
again we have to work within their time
parameters of what they do and and yeah
just a small agenda about kind of what
what you'd like to put to them perhaps
just so that we they've got a rough idea
of what to expect but and yeah there I'm
sure there'd be more than happy to meet
Thank You councillor eben and thank you
very much chair um my question is is for
portfolio holder whichever one of you is
responsible as it were with mine selling
to have we're funding this for a period
of two years and what are their
measurement criteria as to whether it's
a success because honestly you know you
can hear from people in the chamber that
that to date we're all suggesting that
it is a successful way to go but at what
point do we then say do we review it do
we see you know obviously you don't want
to get to the end of the two years and
and Sun stops so do we review it at a
certain point what are the criteria and
how would we decide whether we would
continue funding it thank you very much
Absalom Hollywood judge response done
thank you we are looking at it
periodically as we go along and we will
keep all the statistics and there's no
reason why we wouldn't fund it again but
we will look at what has achieved before
the two years is up just to add to that
we are going to be collecting
performance metrics the impact is and
hopefully rather than you distribute
your report to all councilors perhaps I
can ask Melanie if you put it on our
website and just to say as part of the
service level agreement we did actually
set some performance measures right at
the very beginning so they are actually
actually clearly stated in service level
agreements so what I'll do is I'll show
you that information share that with you
and then obviously you can have the
statistics and things to go with it and
obviously some of the information from
the reports as well
councillor Hicks sorry counselor Madison
for coming and answering so many
questions and can come back next year
and also you mentioned Church walk I
wondered whether you're paying
particular attention to other places
where there are blue badge parking such
as Marriott's walk and crows streets and
second question are they able to deal
with moving traffic issues or not and
the honest answer is that I don't know
in relation to the blue badge areas that
you've mentioned they do have parking
patrol areas and it may be on that list
that they've got and what I would
suggest is just popping in the
and then that will ensure that they do
have a look at that but I can also just
double check with them tomorrow in
relation to moving moving traffic
offenses what sort of things are you
thinking of thank you yeah the the two
prohibited left turns which try to
discourage through traffic in Ipswich
Street shopping center so that they can
they could essentially look to stop or
ask a vehicle to stop they or they could
they could take down details and might
be something that I could I could
discuss with them to just observe obtain
details and we could do that those
warning warning letters again that that
might be a way that we look to initially
deal with it rather than some stringent
enforcement and then we could decide
whether or not it needed to be up to
level I think would probably be where
I'd prefer to come in at that lower
level and then accept to do more
questions and then we'll cook drawers to
a close I'm council Aaron yan
thank you madam chair inspector I happen
to be in receipt of communications from
your good self about the issue of which
would appear to be related to county
lines and I guess my question is that I
can understand that things are being
done but my residents are concerned that
there is no visible visibility of
actions being taken and certain there
are certain hotspots in stone market
that continue to produce problems for
the local residents and yeah I can
understand how that must be frustrating
and for yourself and at this juncture
for your residents or probably for a
prolonged period of time it's very
difficult for you to just place your
total trust in me that when I say we are
dealing with it we are dealing with it
because until and there's some tangible
action scene and that's just difficult
for people to place their faith in us
and I understand that and one sort of
mitigating circumstance style button is
that I've had a recent change in
structure of myosin TT and that is in
the form of losing both of my sergeants
who had a good level of experience and
understanding and knowledge of the the
area and I've got two new sergeants who
are both equally capable and
enthusiastic and just come away from
meeting with them earlier on today in
relation to that area we've got some
really good things that were going to be
putting into practice in place that will
increase visibility but you will also
see a longer-term change there and if we
are successful in what we're trying to
do so again I'm not I'm trying to tell
you something without telling you
everything I'm pretty sure that's
difficult but it certainly is well on
our radar and in terms of our priorities
is number one
lastly councillor Orton
all right I'd like to thank you again
for coming and you know for giving us a
very informative chitchat and and all
these questions so thank you again
no probably welcome and I am so moving
to item at agenda item number 11 MC / 19
/ 15 equality and diversity policy I'd
like to invite councillor Morley to
introduce this paper and to move the
recommendation in the report
Thank You chair members our present to
you an equality and diversity policy
which demonstrates the council's
commitment to embedding the Equality Act
2010 which includes a public sector
equality duty for the right of
individuals to be treated equally and
fairly the Equality Act 2010 brought
together over 116 separate pieces of
legislation into one single act
providing a legal framework to protect
the rights of individuals in advancing
equality of opportunity for all since
the introduction of the Act there have
been many changes to the legislation and
functional and supportive guidance has
been provided to public authorities
it is therefore timely to bring in a
policy to support and provide guidance
including duties and responsibilities in
respect to the 9 protected
characteristics and to cement the way in
which we are carrying out their duties
in line with the act as a council we
have agreed that using equality impact
assessments is the most effective way to
demonstrate that we have paid due regard
these are completed alongside a
screening process for our major
decisions and identify the impacts of
any proposed changes have been
considered according to the protected
characteristics our communities are
becoming more diverse and we support and
foster good relations between protected
groups it is important there are
policies and service delivery reflect
both these diverse and sometimes similar
needs this also includes our workforce
and our commitment to ensure all
officers feel included and play their
part in making the council great places
to live work and visit this equality and
diversity policy is an overarching
document that embeds best practice of
equality and diversity and is supported
by guidance and resource this topic will
continue to evolve and councils are
asked to recommend to cabinet the
frugal of this policy to demonstrate our
commitment to support and promote the
diversity of our communities in
accordance with the Act I would like to
move the recommendation on page 15 to
remain recommend Council adopts equality
and diversity poverty policy which meets
the cursus responsibilities under the
Equality Act 2010 and would ask for a
seconder
thank you could I have a seconder thank
you I'm sure I'd like to second the
recommendation as stated in a paper this
is now open for Question and Debate
cancer those gone
thank you madam chair um well I
definitely welcome the introduction of
equality in diversity policy in this
format but can I give you another
particular example recently we had a
binder in midst of it joint over
scrutiny committee where we were
discussing amongst other issues staff
turnover and welfare and the particular
types of illness related to that at that
meeting quite horrific Lee a member from
not this council fortunately but a
member from paper actually started
clearing about sickness due to pregnancy
now in this day and age that is
completely unacceptable
we all had and I had to say that member
was ruled out of order by Babers
scrutiny chairman instantly although
that didn't stop him trying to press
home the issue we've all had training at
this council and and babe as well but I
would suggest that perhaps some of the
counselors need a refresher on this
because pregnancy sickness is not an
illness and that is a direct to my mind
going to pregnancy or maternity which is
one of our particular characteristics in
this policy so what so welcome the fact
that we're introducing this policy there
are some members from both councils
possibly that actually need to do a lot
more on this
and I would suggest if if that counts
her in particular mashup embarrassing by
name in hasn't undergone in quality and
diversity policy training then they
should do projection response that thank
you for your support to councillor Scott
equality and diversity training is
mandatory for all councillors and if
this particular person has not yet been
on the training he soon will be
councillor otter thank you very much
absolutely surprised that the council
did not already have such an equality
and diversity policy in place so if
that's the case then obviously we're
absolutely delighted that it is now and
I have no doubt will be approved just
for information I am a member of the
County Council's equality for inclusion
board and as part of their there are a
series of networks for example there is
the Women's Network there is a vegan
Network they are gbt networks young
people and I believe in fact some from
mid Suffolk are already joining those so
I think it'd be a really good idea if we
as a council can advertise that and
promote it and if those are you know
available to members and staff then it
seems ridiculous if they're taking place
in this building that not everybody you
know that everybody has the opportunity
to join them
thanks very much just a quick question
really and the document of course we
welcome this and like council I'm
surprised there's an something already
in place but if there isn't at least
we've now got there so fantastic the
only thing I ask is that under Pro point
5 we talk about staff professional
development and under 4.2 which about
all new staff we don't
this document at all about councillors
and I think we should have a paragraph
in here about actually because it's not
just stuff it's scarf and councillors
together it's a joint working and we
should we should both be included so I
would just ask I don't think it needs to
come back but I think we ought to add
some insertion in there about medicine
counselors in the report as well is
there any other questions or comments
and so we'll well we'll move to the
recommendation then all those in favor
that's some unanimous item number 12
which has been moved to item 4 Deeb's
simply item number 13 councillor
appointments are there any changes to
placing the mauling Thank You chair I
would like to propose substituting
counselor how do them for counselor
Richardson on the health and well-being
board thank you thank you do you have a
seconder I'm happy
that's that item number fourteen motions
on notice I would like to invite
councillor Fleming to move the motion
for good evening everyone I'm very
pleased to bring this climate change
motion to mid Suffolk Lancel this
evening and you've all seen the wording
probably but I will read it at the
benefit of anyone who hasn't seen it it
says this is council pledges to declare
a climate emergency to set up a task
force commencing in September 2019 to
examine ways in which favor and mid
suffered actually strictly speaking
that's mid Suffolk in our face will
respond to the climate change challenge
on a spend to save basis with the
ambition to make Weber and MIT suffered
council's carbon neutral by 2030 to work
with partners across the county in
region including the lab public sector
leaders and others towards the
aspiration of making the county of
Suffolk carbon neutral by 2030 and to
work with government to deliver its
25-year environmental plan and increased
the powers and resources available to
local authorities to make the 2030
target easier to achieve well
there must be few of us in this room who
doesn't recognize that we are living
beyond our means awareness is growing
about this dilemma and it's particularly
evident in young people who often show
an instinctive sense of unease about
life in general and has been identified
by some psychologists now as a form of
environmental induced mental stress I
see it in a lot of the young people in
my own family the problem is not just
about the nature of activities it's also
about scale they're almost twice the
number of people living on earth now and
when I was born it must put me back a
bit actually and proportionately they're
living much more extravagantly for
instance the other day I saw in the
paper that in 1996 19,000 people visited
Venice from cruise ships and last year
1.7 million foot the same thing as most
of us know the antidote to worry his
action and I'm very pleased that action
is starting now in addition to our
government declarations of climate
change emergency these are being made in
other countries throughout the world and
in the UK at least 85 local and regional
one or two tier authorities have past
climate emergency measures the list is
growing Suffolk County Council declared
emergency in June and brought a capelet
paper to cabinet from July setting out
how the county proposes to go about
responding there was a clear role for
all Suffolk County Council's to work
together to achieve real progress and I
look forward to bringing mid Suffolk
into that framework to develop and
coordinate environmental action in this
county and through the region so what
next what are we going to do about
mm we as a district council intend to
implement this motion by setting up
firstly a task force along with our
colleagues at paper we will respond to
the climate change challenge in the
widest sense aiming for carbon neutral
by 2010 carbon neutrality by 2030 and
taking into account the relevant
sustainable development goals that
support the key UN goal 13 which
addresses climate change we work with
our partners at is the County Council
the greenest county board in you and the
lab and other local authorities and
organizations and specialist groups
which may be involved in energy
efficiency biodiversity in the
conservation will support the
government's twenty five-year plan and
seek to undertake the changes and
adjustments that will be necessary and
we will repair and port back to
cabinet's and full council this is all
about changing course we cannot expect a
different result if we keep doing the
same thing growth in the natural world
balances decay it enables change to
happen in life to carry on this is the
spirit in which we must couple our need
for economic growth with our
responsibility to maintain quality of
life this is part of my vision for
Suffolk and I hope you share it as a
place which is prosperous but not greedy
it takes responsibility for its actions
and is willing to leave and making
positive changes I ask you all to
consider and support this motion today
could I have a seconder thank you
Thank You chair I'm happy to second this
proposal don't we now move into debate
and questions
councillor melon thank you madam chair
I'm sure we're all very well aware
that's outside this council chamber the
UK is experiencing possibly its highest
ever temperature today and we've seen
weather records being broken across
Europe in the last couple of days I know
we're talking particularly about weather
and not climate but we are living in
unprecedented days where the climate
change is becoming a reality in our
daily lives we on this side welcome the
declaration of a climate emergency and
perhaps people might have wondered if
that proposal that motion would have
come from us on this side as the Green
Party you may think that you've taken
our policy or perhaps you know analogy
you understand on that side you've shot
our Fox what what does this mean though
what does it mean to declare a climate
emergency the Russians have a proverb
which goes something like this fine
words butter no parsnips and words
without actions to back them up are
meaningless
let me give you a quote from Sir David
Attenborough perhaps our most well known
environmentalist climate change is the
greatest threat that's humanity has ever
faced I would love to give you a quote
from our new prime minister on this but
in his words in Downing Street yesterday
the greatest threat that humanity has
ever faced did not even get a mention
it's often said that we need to look for
the solutions to climate change friends
I have to tell you we already have those
solutions we have those answers already
and they are exactly the policies and
practices that me and my colleagues on
this side of that's author of the
chamber have been advocating for years
we already know how to build carbon
neutral homes we just need to have the
political will to set higher buildings
Anders and enforce them we already know
how to reduce the impacts of vehicle
emissions is by encouraging people to
walk to cycle to use public transport
rather than building new roads we
already know how to power our economy
with renewables and it's cheaper than
nuclear we know how to boost wildlife in
our countryside by beefing up corridors
building in transit points for wildlife
into developments and providing the
staffing needed in the relevant council
departments and we'll come to that later
if we really do see climate change as an
emergency which I believe it is then in
a thousand ways in a multitude of
decisions we need to have it at the
forefront of our minds and be making the
right decisions our communities require
it our children deserve it we welcome
this declaration but we wait to see the
reality in the policy and practice of
the council business as usual and
tinkering with what we do will not be
enough Thank You Chancellor field thank
you
and I think I'll keep this brief and not
to try and lecture you all wrong things
you totally understand already my point
would just be that the Lib Dem green and
independent group of the council
introduced a motion of this type there
and it was very it was passed almost
totally unanimously it's hardly
something we're going to oppose here is
it we are really going to be totally in
support we obviously do also agree that
it doesn't need reacting real action
that the committee set up must must move
must do things effectively it's not to
be just words to keep us all feeling
comfortable but I'm sure it that is not
the case I have to commit I admit I have
some slight suspicions about the word
since I spend to save basis I hope that
means to spend to save the planet or
spend to save carbon it doesn't mean
spend you we have to prove that we save
money before we spend but assuming the
wider understanding of those words I
think this group is totally in support
Thank You councillor Humphreys my chair
thank you I won't make this two party
political climate change and everything
that goes with it isn't green isn't
yellow it isn't blue it isn't red it's
everybody we're all in the same planet
we are the same feelings we all express
the same desires you do this government
that's the UK government has led the
world led the world to try and reduce
carbon activity and to help with climate
change that's a fact but it's a whole
government's the whole people
everybody's on board this is a step in
the right direction
the word action in there is good as well
the fact that we're going to form this
task group to go out and examine what's
going on so it can come it's incredible
ways in which we improve the area of mid
Suffolk District Council to help the
world to help this county to help this
district it's not you it's not us it's
all of us I'm Castro casting
it's a fact now that science has proved
that human activity on this planet has
seriously exacerbated climate change I
don't think anyone can deny that now I'm
a conservative and the idea of a
conservative is you can serve things you
always try and take something and pass
it on to the next generation
better than new founder so I think our
government the Conservative government
I'm very proud of what they've done in
2017 we had the lowest greenhouse
emissions since 1988 they need to do
more they are doing more the they're an
inspiration to other countries I'd like
this council to be an inspiration to
other councils with what we do with this
task and finish group if this motion is
approved I think it might be they the
and I wish them a great deal of success
and I'd like to be involved in that as
much as I possibly can Thank You
councillor stringer Thank You Jane I'm
not going to spend too long talking
about it's obviously we support we
believe the spirit of the motion of
course something some of the words are
slightly challenging depending how you
interpret them I'd like to pick up on
the spin to save bases are we honestly
saying that it cost a pound to hit
carbon neutrality in 2013 we wouldn't do
it come on
yeah but I'll take it in terms of just
save it wider environment I think we
need to be really cautious about being
very self congratulatory about the
country does it is true our own
emissions in this country have gone down
but because we've offshored so many of
our manufacturing bases that's how we're
then able to then offset that somehow
the planet doesn't care where you offset
the emission to it cares about the
emission so if we truly want to show the
world how to do it we've got to close
loop some of this stuff a little bit
more be a little bit more forensic with
our examination but and also the
question was well
why haven't the greens put a motion like
this in fact we did precisely a year ago
and it was ruled out by the
administration not the counselors by by
the government's as being too ambitious
and and it was an area that we couldn't
influence within our budget I think
that's what we were told anyway glad to
see there's a motion of sources come
happy to to go along with it but we will
obviously be watching you like a hawk in
terms of making sure that this
aspiration turns into perspiration Thank
You councillor Pratt yeah in terms of
making the difference between what we
say we're going to do and what we
actually do the development of the
Ipswich northern route will no doubt
contribute substantial amounts of carbon
dioxide how does the project fit in with
the objective to being carbon neutral by
2030 and shouldn't it just be scrapped
I'm cancer more research answer that the
Ipswich relief Road is not the subject
for mid Suffolk to discuss it's a County
Council initiative and we await the
results of the consultation that are
taking place at the moment Thank You
councillor eben thank you very much
chair am I to welcome this motion but
just in terms of what countries around
the world are doing I'm China for
example is planting an area the size of
Ireland in trees every year so there you
know if we can kind of do the equivalent
term in mid Suffolk in in scale and I
think that would be a great achievement
what I would like to see really is the
task force being set up in September
this September could we have some really
close definite guidelines in terms of
how long the task force goes for what
it's delivering so it doesn't kind of go
on you know
ad infinitum that we actually have some
clear targets that we're hitting and
that there's a shorter time frame as
possible and
you can then from that embed within
everything that we do the results of
this I know that on the reports that we
have to date we have environmental
implications but I'd rather that didn't
become a tick box that people really
think about the work that we're doing as
a district council how is that impacting
climate change and what are we doing
about it and be embedded in everything
that we do so my question really chair
is is the task force what's the time
frame and can it deliver quickly Thank
You councillor Worley would you actually
answer that your firming I think as the
proposer I think probably else we I
think I'm not going to give a definite
time frame for the duration the task
force my estimate would be it would
report back to council and cabinet
within six months it would be an I
envisioned here across party task force
involving those Baber and mid Suffolk
members and we would look very widely at
what we can do in mid Suffolk it may
seem fairly humble but there are some
real things that we can do differently
I've got some ideas and I look forward
to sharing them with other people on or
off the task force and I see it as a
great opportunity to collaborate with
other local authorities both in Suffolk
and across the UK so I really see this
as something that will give us the tools
to make the changes but I think we all
want to make councillor rich Thank You
chair and I'd like to make a slightly
broader point which I think was touched
upon in in councillor Fleming's comments
about the general well-being of our
communities because personally I work in
the NHS for a national body and I'm
acutely aware of the relationship
between things like air pollution and
subsequent NHS spend on respiratory
medicine and so I really want to to
commend this motion of the
the impact that it will have if if we do
to clara climate change emergency and do
take strong initiatives to be carbon
neutral by 2030 i think that the
benefits we can reap from that and not
just in relation to the environment but
actually can have a much wider benefit
upon our wider communities and in the
health and well-being of the people that
we represent and so i just like to make
that point which is i don't think as we
mentioned that much but the impact on
quality of life and the subsequent
impact on people's health can be really
really improved by this better this
motion and the actions of this council
can take so I really welcome this
initiative thank you would anyone else
like to speak cancer thank you sure to
say that I'm pleased to see this motion
isn't understatement
I think it's a relief that we're
beginning to recognize the seriousness
of the situation we're in and we've had
decades of human activity which has
created the present situation we have
done ourselves a huge hole globally with
regards to the environment and it's this
motion I think recognizes needs to not
only stop digging but to start thinking
about filling that hole in I am however
concerned it has been mentioned
previously about the inclusion of the
phrase spent to save for me it's obvious
it's spending to save the environment
perhaps it's to do with the carbon
footprint emissions or does it imply
that we just spend in to save money I
think we do need to be very clear about
this it is very difficult to put a value
on what measures we undertake to protect
and conserve improve our environment
whatever money that is spent now the
benefits of this investment may not be
messaged in percentages it might not be
seen for decades
we cannot put a value on it I hope I'll
be very comfortable if this motion did
not have that phrase in it because I do
not think simple economics can be put
into it it is about value and I
recognize what counsel Richardson has
just said it is about the well-being of
the people in our communities and
globally so I think I would like to
propose an amendment it's possible that
that phrase be emitted from the motion
do you have a second day
I'm sorry have to debate the amendment
cancel a geek you did want to speak
would you like to you know kick that off
[Music]
does anyone want to speak on the
amendment Jessica would you like to
accept the amendment
so it will go to debate on the amendment
the councillor ebo would try to I mean
sorry fans sir would you like to speak
thank you well perhaps if you're not
willing to accept it can you actually
reiterate what you actually mean by the
phrase to spend to save Chancellor
Fleming do I mean by spend to say I mean
the the financial investments that are
made by the council need to have some
tangible benefit to the people of
mid-summer
councillor mansard you would judge come
back um again a tangible is another word
that that is a little bit subjective so
I'd like a little bit more detail about
what you mean by tangible because you
know it is a very subjective word what
is a tangible reward but I didn't think
this is a matter for cost accounting
because that would be a waste of time I
think we all know that what it means is
there has to be a control on the costs
who as we don't have unlimited money it
means that investments need to have some
you can knowing economic benefit as well
as some environmental benefit to the
people who've suffered and economic
benefit can be a very indirect thing a
health benefit is potentially an
economic benefit I think when you put
costs on things that are essentially
qualitative you run into a lot of
trouble and that's not something I
advocate doing I think we all know when
an investment pays off and that is the
spirit in which I would like us to take
this motion forward Chancellor Carter
I would afford that say the continuation
of existence on this planet was quite a
tangible benefit that's we could all
recognize right now so especially
members of the Buffy climate strikes
Friday climate strike specially you will
see out of schools it session things
where it is highly recognized the
importance of what we do today but there
is again respect it's been saved there's
be economic benefits going back to be
health points however we actually what
we are spending now on ambien HHS for
airborne pollution diseases the cost low
of asthma due to pollution well we would
be having a considerable saiful on that
quietly improving air quality right now
also if you have heard the term green
descriptions where mental health
benefits of actually having trees around
and nature
where you actually have some doctors
would tell you you need to get outside
into nature to fill that - for improved
mental health well that again would have
a economic benefit having if we did say
want to negate some of the carbon by
planting more trees right now have
announced one of the one of the part of
what we're doing is a task force of
planting trees which have a mental
health benefits so that would be
spending and saving on the NHS Haslam
morley I think just a general point is
that the budget for this year has
already been set
and as a fiscally responsible counsel we
cannot and will not exceed that budget
so anything that we do and there are
lots of things that we can do and the
task force will be working cross-party
and cross both councils and we will be
looking at quick wings that we can do
now immediately that's going to save
help go toward saving uh planet
interrupt I do feel that the level of
debate here is gone completely off track
because surely everyone is entitled to
say what they want to say and then the
proposer of the motion and the second
surely have the opportunity to then
answer all of those questions at the
moment it seems as if those I mean I'm
lost
I'm losing track here so I just feel
that the procedure of the debate has
gone a bit off-track
obviously we're absolutely supporting
what has been proposed but I really
would like to hear the answers to those
questions in a clear and precise way
when they can be picked up by those
proposer and the second Thank You
counsel often they will have a chance to
answer the questions at the end should
they wish to this is a debate
yeah it's a spiteful bit on the
environment Cass the geek sorry it's
kind of nice okay you're bringing us
back then on to the debate about finding
tangible benefits for this motion and to
not sort of constrain spending which is
needed to to sort of meet those goals
that you're proposing climate change
will indefinitely and inevitably cause a
loss of biodiversity and therefore
ecosystem functions which translate into
ecosystem services those bring with them
social environmental and economic
benefits to us okay which we have
already mentioned so it does it does
carry a significant economic cost if we
degrade our ecosystems and erode these
ecosystem services okay we will not be
able to we wouldn't be able to replace
them these services are being valued
actually and ecological economists
estimate the value of global ecosystem
services as a hundred and forty five
trillion US dollars per year that is a
value far higher than the world's
combined global economic output
published by the International Monetary
Fund and the World Bank so what I would
ask is that we support this amendment to
not put such an emphasis on a so-called
tangible economic return but to actually
foresee the economic returns that they
is going to make in the future going
forward thank you councillor burn I'm
not sure what it is I'm allowed to say
at this point but I think the amendment
yes indeed well the amendment pure and
simple I would like to say I think it's
it's it's it would prove to be
counterproductive to try to pin this
phrase down too much I don't think we on
this side I don't think the proposer is
talking about it purely and simply in
fiscal terms I think the saving can be
interpreted in all sorts of ways any
effort that's made any expenditure that
we can afford is is going to have a
saving effect on the planet that we're
hoping to look after and conserve so
please don't try to be over prescriptive
about what this what this phrase means
[Music]
councillor Fleming
you can come back into the end okay
sorry sorry
cancel Masterson
Thank You Kari I just wanted to refer to
the the timescales question and you know
we have a budget for this year fiscal
responsibility
the problem the problem is that that
we've got 11 years to to get on to it to
a track of Stapley reducing emissions
climate changing emissions of all sorts
not just carbon actually and it doesn't
fit well with local authority timescales
it's an emergency we may need to move
quicker than that we can't wait for the
joint local plan to be adopted for
example we need to actually be squeezing
now to get changes have started now and
I have the task force will be working to
that end really that is why we don't
want
I spent a save is a phrase from the old
transition budget with fun that we used
to have which has changed its name now
and therefore everybody thinks of it
that those of us that here we think of
it purely in those terms unfortunately
and that's a pity
and I think we've we've probably spelled
out clearly enough that we know what
we're trying to save we're trying to
save the planet not just this year's
budget Thank You councillor geek Thank
You chair I just wanted to welcome
councillor burns very wise and calming
words that what we're trying to save as
in the words of councillor Matheson is
the planet and not money it's just that
spending save is so ambiguous and in the
words of councillor stringer if this was
to have a net cost of summer action was
to have a net cost of say just one pound
with that the words at the moment could
be interpreted in such a loose way as to
suggest that we would not be able to
support it as a council and and I think
we just don't want to have a hostage to
fortune in this way and so I would urge
you with all your wonderful fine words
that have come from this your side of
the chamber to to take out what's
essentially
because some dangerous piece of ID
councillor stringer Thank You Jay I was
gonna wreath right and it's funny
because as the explanation of the phrase
has gone on my fear is increased and not
decreased because for instance we're
looking for some quick wins because
we're bound by this year's budget and
again hang on by 2030 every single one
of those refuse freighters we've got out
there I've got to be doing all of their
work carbon neutral let alone missing a
few houses out they've got me running
off renewables that is a massive task so
I'm sorry there might not be many quick
wins
what there's got to be is some
substantial longer-term planning so that
that's why the spend to safing it
depends on what time frame depending
where quick including the planner in
this and I totally get that so I'm I'm
I'm not happy with the spirit world I'd
quite like to you know I'll rules to be
supporting the amendment I'll encourage
others to do it it might not but don't
let anyone think if I support the
amendment that I'm not supporting well I
think we've collectively getting to as
an understanding of what this actually
means but you can understand why we're a
bit twitchy about the hostage to fortune
because of perhaps some of the
explanations that we've had today thank
you but we can have two more speakers
and then we're going to arm goes to
council of war voice to summer so
councillor Mansell so I think what I
wanted to say has already been said so I
won't
I won't waste Thank You chair I'll be
very very brief can I thank Council the
Berlin for his words that it is
impossible to tie down what spend to say
means the only alternative to living in
is to take it out and I agree with him
we need to take it out um so council of
war voice would you like to sum up on
the amendment
I will sum up very briefly I think it's
been aired very thoroughly and as
councillor stringer says as the debate
has continued the ambiguity of this
phrase as has been expanded upon it
isn't about not being fiscally
responsible I am NOT suggesting that the
council should spend more than it can
afford to do what I am concerned is the
direction in which the council's efforts
go and the way in which we meet this
this challenge it is going to it the
implications of a climate emergency of
profound they affect everything from
planning to the way we travel to our
meat is to development to the use of
energy biodiversity the advice we give
up parishioners and I would not like to
see something being taught to me that
this isn't a good idea because it does
not have a sound economic return we are
not going to save money by taking this
measure but we may be improving our
environment and our futures our
children's futures we don't have the the
rights perhaps to say we cannot spend
now in order to save their futures
councillor Fleming would you like to
sell Oh
I hate to say it but I think it's
disingenuous of the opposition to think
that the council would withhold doing
something that made complete sense for
quality of life just because it costs a
little bit I don't think that is going
to be the case we have a motion here
that is reflected in the motions passed
by other local authorities and suffering
and actually around the country the
wording in Suffolk is the same I don't
want to deviate from the wording that
Suffolk County Council has proposed and
other local authorities have proposed we
need to work together on this if we put
a spanner in the works it's going to
actually be counterproductive to the
objectives that we all want to achieve
and I mean I cannot accept your
Amendment everything else you say you
know it's indisputable we need to take
some action but I think your amendment
is just simply not helpful to that cause
and you must understand that as green
people who believe in actually taking
some action that these kind of trip ups
actually what they are these done you
know costed impediments to doing things
don't help us so I am not accepting the
event thank you
so we're now going to vote on the
amendment so all those in favor and
those against
if the amendment is lost so will now go
back to the substantive motion
has anyone got anything else to say
counselor geek
thank you her chair the National I'm not
very good with a hot day let's just go
back to the action the NPP s it states
the joint local plan should help shape
places in ways that contribute to
radical reductions in greenhouse gas
emissions minimize our vulnerability and
improve our resilience the head of
policy of Town and Country Planning
Association said last year that any plan
made now that does not consider climate
change and energy as central themes will
simply not be fit for purpose now the
joint local plan takes us up to 2036
that is well beyond 2030 so can I just
urge us all in our deliberations on this
motion can we consider also whether our
new joint local plan will contribute to
our becoming carbon neutral or just to
tinker around the edges that's the first
thing I know that's not for today that's
for the joint local plan but if we
accept this then we've got to think
about that the other thing that I would
like to to say is that given councilor
Molly's response to councilor Pratt can
can we now assume that that all of you
lovely people opposite who have said
such marvelous things today and who have
commended this motion in quite strong
terms with that you'll all respond to
the consultation on the Ipswich northern
relief Road by saying that it should not
be built and that the money should be
used instead spent on cycling walking
and public transport because that is the
only way that we will become the
greenest County and carbon neutral by
2030
so councillor Fleming would you like to
sum up or should we go straight to the
boat I think we should go straight to
the boat
so all those in favor of them
substantive motion right that's
unanimous and carries thankfully so
moving on sarong 14b and the motion on
notice received from councillor eben i
would like to invite councillor Byrne to
move the motion thank you very much sir
given the vote that we've just had we've
all in this chamber agreed to the
importance of of acting now and what is
really vital is what we as a as a
district can do you'll see the the
motion in your papers and what we're
asking for the council to do is to
pledge that a task force reviews
recognized and potential wildlife
corridors in the district and brings
forward proposes proposals to enhance
these corridors that we also pledged for
additional Borah cultural and
biodiversity advisory resources are made
available as necessary to both support
the task force provide more input to
support planning officers strengthen the
role of the public realm team and
provide adviser to parishes and other
community landowners and that to do this
additional resources or applied during
the this financial year 2019 2020 and
are funded if if not available from the
current budget then from the growth and
efficiency of the fund and that they're
considered for the budget in future
years
this whole motion comes up more and more
frequently at the moment it's raised at
parish council meetings biodiversity is
mentioned in planning committees and in
discussions in with the public and we
need to ensure that we're acting on it
now and we are doing everything that we
can to improve the biodiversity now this
can be the simplest of thing
leaving grass uncut how many of you have
had discussions about verges about
leaving areas of village greens uncut to
allow wildflowers to grow and the
biodiversity to improve it's about
allowing green corridors to be left
alongside new developments it's about us
putting forward proposals to ensure new
developments and new developments
themselves cater for this whether this
is Hedgehog highways or green roofs but
we can't do this with no resource and
what we need to do is support our senior
management in planning for a well
resourced team to make this possible so
I urge everybody in this chamber to
support this motion and to this end I
propose the motion and ask for seconder
Thank You chair thank you could I have a
second I would like to second the motion
and outline my reasons thank you madam
chair thank you and so the council
recognizes the threat posed by climate
change to human security biodiversity
loss is compounded by climate change but
it is coupled to the change and
intensification of the way that we use
our land in the last century Suffolk has
lost 96% of species rich grasslands up
to 80% of hedgerows and 10% of its
ancient woodlands and with that numerous
species of wild flowers butterflies and
other invertebrates this highlights not
only the need to safeguard and
strengthen existing designated and
county wildlife science but to identify
new opportunities to support threatened
species and enhance the connectivity of
habitats our new task force would advise
planning officers in the incorporation
of green infrastructure such as green
walls and green roofs and the earliest
stages of development proposals as
recommended in the revised planning
practice guidance working with local
nature partnerships they will also
identify opportunities to create new
sites and enhance existing ones and plan
for optimal use of that space these
spaces will provide invaluable benefits
to human being human wellbeing how
and livelihoods for example species-rich
meadows as we've mentioned plays a
fundamental role in purifying our water
recycling organic litter and nutrients
and pollination Road verges and
two-thirds of amenity grassland a closed
mon but plans to allow wildflowers to
flourish in these sites is gaining
popularity there is also opportunity for
riparian planting and restoration along
the rivers Ratan Gipping to improve
water quality and restore habitat
diversity so members of the public have
been forthcoming in their support for
these measures and these are just a
couple of really simple ways in which we
could strengthen the nature recovery
network and set out in the government's
twenty five-year environmental fan this
year the World Wildlife Fund reported 56
species that's 25% of Suffolk's bees are
either threatened or a conservative
conservation concern now as we all know
of course bees pollinate wild plants and
crops and are vital to our local economy
these benefits are also known as
ecosystem services which I touched on
earlier the revised natural environment
guidance papers endorses and ecosystem
services approach to valuing these
services our new biodiversity offices
could play a pivotal role in
implementing this plan through collating
biodiversity data and helping planners
incorporate the value of ecosystems to
inform decision making processes and
I'll just finish on the point that
averting a dramatic decay of
biodiversity in the subsequent loss of
ecosystem services is still possible
through considerate planning and
intensified conservation efforts but
that window of opportunity is rapidly
closing
so I would like to ask you all to vote
for this motion to give the council the
support it needs to fulfill our
sustainability goals going forward and
put Suffolk on the map as the UK's
greenest County thank you very much
thank you
now that matter is open for debate
cancer the Guthrie
yes thank you yes obviously a lot of
things you've said that for example the
bees I'm fortunate enough to live next
to a farmer who's just planted six acres
specifically for the bees and it is most
important
I was also rather saddened this morning
to be out at seven o'clock in the
morning to see a hedgehog flattened on
the road in front of me which was really
sad we do need to assist and but one
thing I do ask everybody including
Suffolk County Council to take note that
rag Burt is poisonous to grazing animals
cattle horses donkeys etc so we do need
to be a bit careful about what we do and
we don't cut Thank You councillor thank
you yes I'll be supporting this motion
apologies to those of you that come to
another chamber leaves an anecdote have
already used here when I was born in
1964 my parents used to play music to
get me a goat sleep because the parent
has a bit of a rarity child and one of
the singles Aesop labels by a band
called the Beatles which you're probably
familiar with John Paul George and Ringo
since 1964 when I was born we've lost
two of those Beatles they've lost 50
percent we've also lost 50 percent of
the species of beetles on this planet we
need to look at this very very seriously
and and and I think it's quite
interesting those of you we had a drive
round after Frank committee with
councillor Barker to look at previous
mistakes and good points about what had
been built I think that was some of
those trips were did visit good practice
and somewhere there was frankly horrific
practice where there wasn't a centimeter
left and concreted and and you know that
the quality of life those people doing
there was going to be diminished by that
so I think there is an important role
for us but of course you've got to get
the story straight if you're heading
towards a developer to saying by the way
I wanted you to put a hedgehog hole in
that fence what all you need to remind
me it's actually less material you need
to use that's one one little bit less
offense you need to put in actually it's
less material so therefore it could be
of cost benefit to you so I think we
need to make sure that we get this on
track there are some good examples and
in Suffolk farmers have been trying to
reverse the depletion in bumblebees and
other bees but in isolation little
pockets in isolation is great but what
we need to do is form those corridors
everywhere so that everywhere can join
up and and yeah and and along with our
tree for life screen which we kicked off
last year which I'm not sure if how to
spend to save model but it's certainly
giving us a huge amount of benefit in
terms of kudos with the public as well
as spreading some biodiversity out there
into the general public and hopefully
pollinating bees thank you
cancer opinion thank you madam chairman
and of course we are all very keen to
improve the climate but I think we've
just recently had a very successful Food
and Drink Festival in stock market and
one of the things that struck me about
that was the wide range of produce and
other products that came from Suffolk
and if we're going to be very serious
about how we help the economy how we
help climate change and so on we could
at least start by making sure that we
buy stuff that's local and if we can't
buy from Suffolk and Lee's let's buy
let's buy from Britain and I think that
would help our farming friends as well
as the rest of us and I commend you to
think about that as we move forward
councillor mojo thank you I think all
your points irrelevant and and well said
actually I definitely support your
motion I'll get that in the open right
now because I think all your points are
relevant but let's not beat ourselves up
too much we do do a good job in mid
Suffolk on the planning the Chairman's
the actual committee members we do our
very best to make sure that developers
follow that path for biodiversity for
green for everything else that's good in
the world so we're not we don't just go
yeah go and build it's just concrete
world actually we do our very best to
prevent that and and really we should do
more but we can only do that together if
you've got good ideas let's share those
good ideas and let's move forward and
the other good thing is I drove from
stone market to here and one of the most
most sort of carbon areas are our main
roads the a12 is a classic the 814 as
well now we've got lots of traffic down
there we still need roads by the way so
when we get electric cars they'll sting
me to drive on roads so northern bypass
I think we might still need it that's
another subject but I drove down that
road and this is where all that carbon
is generated locally and for 75 percent
of that whole journey from stone market
so the as to turn off I can pretty much
say there are constant lines of trees
constant and where the trees were
missing for the extra 20 percent
there were hedgerows there's five
percent of nothing what we need to do
collectively is fill up five percent of
trees luckily the government is released
funding and a really good project to
plant every million trees and they get
your point about China they don't forget
the Rossa building six cities a day so
we all we all need to work together to
improve things but I think down our
planning we're doing our best with this
motion I think we're going to do a
little bit more and yeah I will be
supporting it Thank You councillor
Fleming thank you yes I will be
supporting this motion
I think anyone who knows me knows how
important Iraq biodiversity and
ecosystem management how highly
important they are to us achieving a
quality of life and also our climate
change objectives
so yes I will be supporting this and I
just wanted to throw in a an idea behind
I picked this letter out actually to
draw attention today to the fact that
the civil engineering Contractors
Association has written to Lord gardener
about non-native species and
biodiversity in the construction sector
and I will distribute it to councillors
because there's some very interesting
reading here we're missing a lot of
invasive species that are coming in
through various means but at the
assessment stage and this is a planning
issue we need to put more effort into
training people to recognize things that
other than just a narrow range of
species that everyone looks for because
there are a much wider range of both
animal and plant creatures being brought
in that are very destructive than are
being missed they also have the Port of
Felixstowe in Suffolk which is a major
corridor for bringing invasive species
into this country so these are the sort
of things that I think we as a council
as a country can really work to improve
so yes I look forward to to putting some
teeth in this motion I'm cancelling
would you sum up before I vote
come on there Dave Thank You Man
the motion we are considering here
contributes positively and powerfully to
the previous one we just agreed it is in
my opinion a vital part of protecting
not only our natural world for Toms sake
but also the world for the value of its
contribution to our own health and
well-being and let's face it the health
of the planet as a whole we are running
out of time though and if we are to beat
this thing we should all be working in
earnest now the motions been brought by
members on the other side of this
chamber but I have absolutely no
hesitation in supporting it
wholeheartedly playing politics for its
own party as a sorry playing politics
for its own sake has no part in this
we're all equally affected by the usage
we should be working equally to combat
them I am unashamedly a conservative for
the capital C but I'm also with a
lowercase G as green as a cabbage
through and through
councilor in Bern would you like to sum
up
thank you very much chair I'd like to
thank everybody for their contributions
and their words of wisdom in support of
this motion and I hope that what we can
do is actually seal some see some real
benefits to mid Suffolk and particularly
in what we do in planning and what we do
in housing and to start work on on this
straightaway and I would hope that we
can get something going immediately and
be able to report back within the next
few months
and not waste time but I don't everyone
to support the motion thank you again
all right all those in favor of the
motion
I think that's unanimous
all right
agenda item 12 the capital investment
fund trading Cisco capital business
limited business trading a performance
report before we commence can I ask
members to ensure they refrain from
asking any questions that relate to any
information that is in the exempt papers
until the meeting moves into closed
session it is also my intention to move
the record Ruth move the recommendations
and vote on them in open session
therefore they maybe need to move from
open to closed session and then back
again thank you I would like to invite
councillor Brewster chair wha'd suffered
district council Suffolk Holdings
Limited to introduce his paper and move
the recommendations in the report thank
you madam chairman yes this report sets
out Cisco Capital Limited broadly known
as judy citko
trading activity in 2018 to 19 reporting
performance against key performance
indicators set in the various in the
previous years business plan the report
confirms that the first tranche of
investment was completed in March 2019
creating a portfolio which delivers a
net initial yield the 5.75% generating a
net income
after costs to bathe and mid Suffolk of
1.4 million per annum appended to the
report in confidential appendix a is the
draft business plan for 2019 to 20 which
sets the targets and investment criteria
for the forthcoming year the business
plan has been prepared by the board of
Cisco in consult in consultation with
its fund managers Jones Lang LaSalle it
has been approved by the council holding
companies and endorsed by the joint
overview and scrutiny committee it was
also approved by Baber District Council
earlier this week the business plan
forms an important part of the
governance of the company it is in the
confidential papers due to the
confidential tenant lease information it
contains however the majority of the
information regarding the strategy and
finances of Cisco have been included
within the supporting paper on the open
agenda the managing director Emily at-at
ATAC the chair of Cisco Chris Hayworth
and Nigel Golda from Jones Lang LaSalle
who I welcome there was those members
here and they are here to answer any
questions and I propose these in open
session unless they relate to specific
tenant lease terms I would therefore
like to propose that the recommendation
set out in the section 3 of this report
are approved and I seek a second but
please you don't have a second thank you
councilor Manson
thank you I would like to suggest I
don't whether it has to be a formal
proposal or not or whether I could just
suggest that the two motions the two
recommendations 3.1 at 3.2 can be voted
on separately because I think they are
very different
mosha recommendation okay fair enough
now open for debate in questions I do
have I do have a question and it does
relate to a page reference in the
confidential papers so I don't think it
refers to anything financially
specifically but no I'm sorry I'm using
the online version I don't think the
page numbers are the same on my version
it's page 66 in section 8 and it talks
about if I just find that page so I know
I'm talking about sorry and it talks
about the key investment criteria and I
just wondered whether we could just hear
it does say that they haven't been
changed fundamentally and I just
wondered whether they could hear what
the original or how different they are
from the original investment criteria
because obviously they're changing in
this business plan Emily would you like
to answer this
good evening and the investment criteria
is set out in section 8 of the business
plan and the fundamental changes were
probably in relation to the target yield
which there was a slight adjustment so
the previous business plan the target
yield with 6% whereas in the proposed
business plan the target yield is five
point seven five percent that was
largely to reflect our experience from
the market of the last trading year and
that five point seven five to seven was
more realistic and we also looked at the
lot size and there is a a slight change
in lot size but that's really to reflect
the size of the portfolio rather than a
change in the principal so the
principles remain the same but in terms
of the portfolio we were looking at two
tranches of fifty million so a hundred
million portfolio so as to reflect that
and the the other detailed changes were
probably in relation to the sectors that
we were looking to invest in and they
showed a probably moving towards
investing more in industrial properties
and office properties and alternative
sectors whereas previously we had a
little bit more waiting in the retail
sector and again that was to reflect the
the markets performance over the last 12
months I don't know if Nigel and golden
wants to add anything further I would
just actually just support exactly what
Emily said it's factually correct the
reason why the target has changed
slightly is that portfolios become less
it's become so more
diverse so we have as a consequence
flowed the yield target by fracture but
it also reflects where the current
commercial property market sits as well
thank you I'm counselor field yes
problems for the pink papers I wanted to
ask a question about the revaluation
comment sort of made okay basically then
you talk about a revaluation of
properties and a number of charges that
were made for things I seem to remember
it says things like tax that which have
resulted in a 3.1 million loss to the
account so just wonder if you've got to
explain that in a little more detail so
the and the paper on and the open agenda
sets out that cisco has made a loss for
approximately 3.1 million over the last
trading year and that figure is broken
down and has two main components so the
first is and in respect of the costs
that have been incurred to date in a
firing the asset so they could be seen
as set up costs so they include stamp
duty and professional fees for acquiring
the assets the the amount that relates
to that is approximately one and a half
million the other one and a half million
and relates to the revaluation of the
portfolio so the portfolio will be
revalued on an annual basis and so that
will reflect the fluctuations in capital
value in the market so the put excuse me
sorry the portfolio is revalued in march
and there was a downwards valuation of
approximately one and a half million and
these damn words valuation was primarily
and
a result of reduction in value in the
retail properties that had been acquired
largely due to market sentiment towards
retail investment properties in the
market so the income and the tenants in
place is still maintained and they're
not there aren't any current risks in
relation to that but the market as a
whole is assessing that retail
properties are less attractive and to
acquire and as such that has had an
impact on the capital value of those
properties and the downwards valuation
of the portfolio is in the order of
three percent and in terms of the retail
assets performance against other market
and properties their performance has
actually been better than other
properties in the market so that
reduction in value that we've seen on
those retail assets other retail assets
have actually seen a more significant
reduction in value does that help to
answer your questions I think so but the
way I interpreted that then is the
capital value has gone down by about
twice the amount that you've received
from rental so currently we're sitting
on a one-and-a-half million loss is that
correct and the one and a half million
pounds is income to the council after
after the council's borrowing cost so
that's income the the loss in the syph
accounts is effectively a capital loss a
book loss and so it doesn't affect the
income that comes into the council
through the rents that are being paid
through cific oh so there is a
difference so I don't think it's as
straightforward to offset the revenue
against the capital loss and but I
appreciate what you're what you're
saying it's just not how I would
interpret that that's a stringer yeah I
have to say I'm the earlier question
wasn't
she answered correctly the original
business plan for Cisco had a small
element of higher yielding higher risk
investments which we never did because
the market got bit more volatile and
edgy so we decided not to do them and
we've denied that's happened all the way
through we've had to drag this out of
various portfolio holders you know to
actually get that information and now
when the direct question is asked what
is the difference between this business
case and the original one it's that the
higher risk investments have been
airbrushed out that's fine at least can
we please say that's what we've done I'm
happy to say that I'm sorry I didn't
pick that reference up from your
question earlier it wasn't deliberately
trying to as try to avoid that so the
board of Cisco has made a conscious
decision and to avoid the more riskier
assets in the market and that is and
that has resulted in a lower yielding
but safer property portfolio and that
was something that the board continues
to assess on a and on a monthly basis
when looking at opportunities but it was
felt that that was the appropriate
action to be taken and we continue to
assess that the other factor in in
relation to that is really the
performance of the market so as the
prime yields for better quality more
secure assets and lower effectively so
they the price increases against the the
rent you see a similar shift with
secondary properties so that those
secondary properties that are higher
risk actually become more expensive and
so the risk and reward return isn't
proportionate so at this point in the
market it hasn't been appropriate to
invest in those properties because the
reward hasn't been sufficient to
compensate the risk that we were taking
the board of Cisco will continue to
review and its criteria for investments
and the strategy moving forward but it
does need to be agile and adaptable to
the market conditions
and so I hope that answers that inquiry
councillor Orton thank you
reading the report and the report from
the scrutiny committee there are
obviously some very sensible questions
about the impact of brexit and at six
point nineteen the statement there says
however overall markets have been
confident but matters are likely to
improve once it has been come it has
become known how breath it will be
attained at the moment members I feel
completely unaware of just how brexit
will be contained in the further report
it appears that the Board of Directors
are very confident that there will be no
drastic result of any no deal and I hope
that we do not sit here in the future
months with these investments which have
been badly affected by the uncertainty
and the possibility of the new prime
minister taking us out with no deal um
is there any other questions
councillor Eva thank you very much chair
I've got two questions if I may firstly
on the key performance indicators
exception section five I note that of
the three main indicators they were all
just not quite met I just wanted to get
a view on whether there was going to be
any adjustment to those or change
changes to how to which indicators we
were looking at and then secondly if I
may
at 10.3 in a little bit more detail the
fees that are being that that come with
zip code capital and the increases and
could they just confirm whether the
increase in fees is to do with increase
because it's a percentage or because
there have been actual changes in those
fees that are that are being added to
the zip code for polio thank you very
much and if I can respond just on the
point of fees initially so the figures
that are set out in ten point three are
an estimate of what fees potentially and
cost could be moving forward assuming
that the portfolio grows in size so fees
are a percentage of the portfolio value
so there is a connection between those
those two elements and with regard to
the key performance indicators I'm just
trying to find a section in the report
and with the updated kpi's so just bear
with me for one second so I believe that
the I think it's section eight within
the business plan of the revised
kpi's and so in terms of the yield
performance so that reduces to the five
point seven five but if you just bear
with me one second I'll just have a
quick flick through to check I've got
the right section
upon apologies it's actually section 12
of the business plan and that sets out
the proposed key performance indicators
for 2019 2020 so and you'll see from
that that there's a reduction in the net
initial yield were also suggesting that
we use the equivalent shield as a
performance measure the equivalent yield
helps to show the performance of the
portfolio as a whole not just the
acquisition yield which is what the net
yield is effectively it also looks at
performance against the 24 month period
for completing the second phase of
funding and we've also introduced a
further KPI which is looking at and rent
arrears as well so those are the
proposed KPIs for the next financial
year any other questions
councillor Brewster would you like to
sum up thank you madam chairman yes I
mean there have been some excellent
questions asked and I believe that
they're of the answers have been very
forthcoming I would just go back to the
question of the what is perceived as the
loss of the paper loss technically and I
would remind councillors that actually
the that isn't a loss to loss of rent at
all and the rents are forthcoming they
are sewn covenants and I think once
before in this chamber I mentioned when
we were receiving the training for James
joined the cell that there was a
straight line at the purchase price of
the
acquisition obviously at times the price
will dupe down if there is a little bit
of pressure or recession or anything
like that and if we don't have to sell
the property for any reason properties
go below that line they come up above
the line and provided you aren't selling
you're not it's not a loss so I would
just remind them because of that
but thinking that I'm chairman continue
okay so we move to a boat we'll take the
first two recommendations three point
one and three point two history just
three point one was it okay we just
three point one then the council notes
that go cap to a limited trading
activity and performance for the year to
end eight for 2019 all those in favor
that's unanimous
so I'm three point two and three point
three together right sorry this is three
point two all those in favor
all those against that's carried in
thank you and so that the the date of
the next meeting is Thursday the 26th of
September and I'd like to take this
opportunity to remember to remind
everyone that I'm having my Chairman's
charity on the 31st of August at
Wingfield barns and our kind of like you
also apparently but I'm happy to take
care there's a donation for home start
thanks very much
the meetings closed